Todo Carnaval tem um F de alguém que se
perde tem gente que leva a sério o
negócio de brincar carnaval e leva os
meninos meio da rua meio da folia meio
da Todo Carnaval tem o menino
que se perde olha aqui como
Zaqueu eu quero
subir Olha Mais Alto olha que que eu
puder Atenção atenção a banda baixinho a
banda bem baixinho por favor a banda
baixinho agora aqui ó criança perdida
aqui perto do trio elétrico pelo amor de
Deus gente quem foi o pai dessa criança
Como é teu nome menino é Joaquim é por
que tava brincando aqui perto com a
minha mamãe ela tava dançando mais um um
cabo aqui que ela que ela tava pronto
pronto aqui o Joaquim ó joaquinho tá
aqui perto tio el por favor quem for o
pai desse menino venha buscar o pai
desse menino venha buscar
menino joaquinho tá chorando aqui gente
quem vier quem for responsável por essa
criança por favor vi buscar o menino
aqui perto da caixa de som olha lá que
eu quero sub
vai